I CALL THE THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH MEETING OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO ORDER MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MORNING MORNING HERE
RAFI RAFI HERE WILK SAYS IT WILL
HEAR ATKINS YOUR ACTIONS HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND LET ME
START BY SAYING WELCOME TO I
MISS BATES AND WE'RE THRILLED TO
HAVE YOU HERE --
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE QUICK WALL
THIS AGENDA LOOKS LIKE A LIFE.
IT IS -- AS
THE EFFORT OF WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR QUITE AWHILE WITH
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS --
TO FORM --
THE SELECT COMMITTEE REQUEST AS
WELL AS ESTABLISH OUR JOINT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS SO.
I BELIEVE I CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
ON ANY AND ALL OF THE ITEMS THAT
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE --
THERE.
FOR OKAY AND THAT WOULD BE UNDER
THE JOINT COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS.
ONE THREE SIX THE SELECT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS SEVEN
THROUGH [inaudible] TWENTY FIVE
NO TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE AND
THEN OF FLORIDA KNOWLEDGE
MINUTES TWENTY TWO THREE TWENTY
FIVE IS THAT.
ANY ONE HAVE ANYTHING THEY WANNA.
OKAY PEOPLE HAVE DONE THEIR
HOMEWORK IN ADVANCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MA'AM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS I CAN SIGN.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES --
IF THERE'S NO FURTHER BUSINESS
WE WILL BE ADJOURNED